non-minimalists
is there a certain point at which you
can justify getting
rid of something and replacing it with
something different even if the initial
item works perfectly well
for example i have baby clothes i have
saved that i have used for my three
children
and we are planning on having more
children eventually however the clothes
i have
aren't necessarily what i would choose
now if i were to go
start over so same with like something
like
dishes like if i have cups that work
perfectly well but i would really prefer
to have a different sort of cup can it
really be justified
replacing it you know i dig this
question ryan because
well it's a nuanced question because
it seems to me that becca isn't just
trying to
she's being intentional about yeah there
are some things in my life
either my preference has changed or i've
become more refined over time
there are some things in my life that i
would
i would prefer to have something
different
and she's saying when can i justify it
and i actually think that word is
is the problem because quite often we
can justify
anything man absolutely i i i bet you if
you give me
48 hours and and a piece of paper
i will write you a really good
justification one that's fairly sound at
least in my mind because that's the only
person i need to really justify it too
i could justify buying a lamborghini
ryan yeah dude we could justify
buying a helicopter i mean if we really
sat there and looked for reasons i
you know i think when it comes to that
word justify the question that i ask
myself is why am i trying to justify
this
and to whom am i trying to justify man
yeah because if it's like if i'm
justifying something
just to give myself permission to do
something
that i typically wouldn't do like for me
that's the wrong
reason for me to justify something yeah
and yeah if it's if it's just
if it's to justify it to myself i've got
to examine that and really ask like what
is it that i'm after here
uh with me with uh cell phones for
example like i still got the iphone five
it's slow as heck because apple does not
update they don't fix the software they
intentionally
let the phone slow down uh that came out
in the news
earlier this year so like they
intentionally uh let the phone get
slower
so you can justify getting another phone
and so i could justify that i could look
at that and say oh my phone's really
slow
and um i need to get that iphone 10 or
maybe i don't go all out and i get the
iphone 8
i don't know what happened to the iphone
9. but uh
i could go i mean i have i could go i
get the iphone 8 and i could totally
justify that it's got a better camera
and it's going to be faster i mean those
are two
those are two pretty valid reasons to
justify but when i really examine it
uh i i wish i didn't have a phone at all
first off
so i don't really want my phone to be
any faster i don't want to be able to
pacify myself easier oh yeah i i i in
fact um
i have you and i've talked about this i
haven't really pulled the trigger on it
yet but like i've
uh talked to you about you've talked to
me about getting like a flip phone and i
mean i think that's what leo about this
still does he still got like a
a dumb phone i guess is what you would
call it yeah um but
but yes um becca you can absolutely
justify
anything but i think with her question
man it goes back to what you're talking
about dude her preferences
when she talked about uh well with her
preferences like the baby clothes
right or the dishes right and so the
question that i wrote down for becca
and this is a question that anyone needs
to ask themselves
is can you afford your new preferences
yeah because yes i mean maybe i would
prefer
to own a range rover i think they're
beautiful cars
but they're also like a hundred thousand
dollar car and
i can't afford that preference is the
range rover is that the one where they
say buy two of them because one's always
in the shop
yes yeah so so really you'd have to buy
two of them if you're gonna buy one
well i could just keep my toyota for
when the uh
but then i'm gonna be discontented
because i'm not driving the range rover
and so i think a range rover is a just a
gorgeous car
i really do think it's a piece of art
it's a it's a moving piece of art
and unfortunately it
i i don't have unlimited money and so i
can't
i can't truly afford it i also can't
afford all the times i would be taking
it to the shop and
and all these additional costs that are
embedded in that i think the other thing
too for me is like when i think about
the tesla and i talked about this a few
episodes ago
where you know mariah and i we had a
savings account set aside for a tesla
and those cost um sixty thousand like
the one i was looking at all-wheel drive
um it's uh the model three it was like
60 grand
and i was you know saving up i pretty we
had ten fifteen thousand dollars saved
up
and i was thinking about dropping that
money
on the tesla just the fifteen thousand
dollars and that was something i
couldn't do because
when i asked myself you know not not
only
like can i afford to buy this tesla but
the
the question i asked myself was can i
afford to buy this tesla
and also not afford to uh build
schools in in thailand so what's the
other use of this money
what's your sort of opportunity cost
there is this the best use of this money
for me
and it's not a judgment by the way if
you were to say yes this range rover or
this tesla
or these new baby clothes or these new
dishes
are the best use of this money for me
that's up to you to determine now
i like the way she looked at it she said
you know what if i had to do this again
would i buy these items again it sounds
to me like the answer is
no now if you're thinking about getting
rid of something
that is the perfect question for you to
ask yourself i love that
if you're gonna get rid of something
then ask yourself
would i buy this again if the answer is
no then yeah you probably want to get
rid of it now if you're talking about
upgrading the thing or the word she used
which i like a lot better
replacing the thing because to me
replacing is far
more important than upgrading because we
get to a point where
okay let's say your phone just smashes
into a thousand pieces right ryan
are you going to upgrade it well maybe
maybe you need a a different version or
just the newer version that's out
yeah or maybe that version that it broke
isn't available anymore right
or maybe you can just replace it with
something else maybe it's the dumb phone
maybe it's another iphone 5 that's used
if you're replacing it that is often
intentional and then so the question is
what am i going to replace this
with is that's a much better question
man i think because it's like
you instead of asking yourself am i
doing this to upgrade
like you know becca needs to ask herself
am i doing this to replace
the items it's a like you said it's much
more intentional yes indeed so
becca i would love to send you a copy of
our book essential
it is an essay collection with 150
different essays here
um jordan which camera is it this one
all right beautiful
um it's an essay collection with 150
different essays about
simple living about intentional living
there are two chapters in here in
particular that i think you'll find a
lot of value in there's a chapter about
minimalism it's the first chapter
and there's another chapter in there
about stuff
and so when you're talking about
replacing your stuff getting rid of your
stuff
some rules around the stuff in your life
we have those rules in essential so sean
if you could reach out to
becca and send her a copy of essential
either the book version or if you like
our podcast you'll love the audiobook
version of essential or if you just want
the ebook
we'll be happy to send that to you as
well